we call to a bit early shortfall in
terms of personality but that's just you
know a scott say a good team in the end
perhaps of very young can be here
because of nolan family matter described
as getting on top and and then we had
needless got up from Yale who come here
from very very face all the influenza so
where are between people up this morning
I just determined that I was just giving
the speakers and get on with it ah but I
inhabit sensations that something's not
quite right and so I think is that I
peers the panel by saying a couple
things about my experience reflections
on what is the sedative for sale or
conferencing about Mediterranean and
cold war are the compliments to your
scale yeah about same topic during which
we essentially spend two days discussing
what is their war and what is the
Mediterranean and yesterday only
governing the proceedings wats the same
very concerning are not it's hard its
way that we hope you spend today just
nothing better questions well arm is the
curb or a meaningful category in what
sense is a meaningful
standing something pools that lady is a
Mediterranean processes religion etc
that's wrong so I think from my
perspective oh it may be that that door
actually faces are these are essential
questions I have my own take on this and
I thought because I say because it extra
tips for the two talks with in here are
this morning are a little bit by my own
state form is for a section on this
first Asian region eliminates at bars
bigger and smaller animation state are
in this case bigger our ears the
Mediterranean and what the jet is meant
for any a feature let us say something
that could appear if you want to put it
invaded Korean firms as an object of
policy what does it take for the
Mediterranean as a region is a region to
appear in a new physical context or in a
policy context coriko book my brother's
to transit again they give them
obviously the Mediterranean is a
physical entity of sorts and even though
regions anywhere or our definition to
coin a phrase constructive they are not
pretty naturally given in the case of
the Mediterranean it is very much
tilting towards the pressure actually
given that is a is a physical space it's
in fact very interesting from that angle
a an inland sea it's the one killing
Lance ease that exists in the world and
so the regional aspect of the
Mediterranean is
to give you an idea for it or
conventionally given confusingly given
or by the fact that it's an inland sea
2,000 years three thousand years four
thousand years it is essentially a very
good way of navigating at least in
summertime it's this point of view as a
native species order for organ or fourth
wasting cracking lameka and so instead
of it the fact of transportation makes
this into a quote on quote natural
region for a couple of millennia it's
one of the best places to set up a
communication system it's cheaper to
transport grain from Spain to Babylon in
antiquity than it is to transport grain
10 15 20 miles in lab and I'm not
talking about the monkey to learn so it
is a good space for communication and
thereby tension a region in that sense
of course it achieves in Gregor urban
times two different versions or in
pressure in the Roman mind becomes
totally integrated into them region um
that are be compared to other Inland Sea
source namely Audrey and the way in
which the book accountant region and a
good way wish to open ceases to be a
region depending on Gio Ponti the vortex
is a lead Lancey an economic region in
the hands of hearing and in his
territory integrated in period of
Swedish dominance or the 17th century
when it comes they said free as we
explained and you bring up Swedish time
no I know that 50 unite our yard had the
option
is driving and one may be seen by
Canadian it ceases to be a regent safety
21 when Peter act ejects the swings then
the eastern seaboard of the vaulting
ceases to be of the integrated part of
the home from the midpoint of smooth and
from then you know it's not been really
a region in a strong sense until recent
years when suisse gave trying to come to
New million waves reinvent is a project
for the ugly website indeed in the
intimate draining case are in ceases to
be an integrated regional course because
disco and because of the instruction in
total destruction the Roman Empire and
says cup left to right or west to east
or east-west are in the middle for a
number of years for your physical
reasons so it ceases to be a region
despite its natural contact system
objective or physical contact our system
is then reconnected which we talked
about edges in this conference and
preceding conference treated any reason
why in the nineteenth and twentieth
century of climaxing in the 20th century
are a north-south axis Western European
dominance our expansion control over the
southern tip top from North Africa or
wherever to are the remnants of the
awesome
viennese so again the can't a region of
sorts but alternative different kind of
basis then in the greco-roman airport so
geopolitics of sorts or economics
economic and geopolitical vision or
process had kind of destroyed destroyed
the region first and then reconnected it
in other terms that then raises the
issue decolonization in the early period
of the tunnel which are come back our
region's coming good I mean for example
Central Europe remember Central Europe
Central Europe is in German I during the
early 20th century has been great you're
also armed for the Germans to expand
economically and politically ah that
comes today it comes to an end very
forcefully through the world over to
Andrew the ensuing divisions of the
total at the Mandarin Mediterranean had
much much stronger geographical unity
attached to it as a Waterman I mean
deserting then becomes different
actually perfectly warm spring orange
juice in the 1840s and confrontation
quality of these ships I'm excited to
get that in a Napoleon couldn't move his
army and Italy the neuromas good but
once you get railroads and once he gets
steamed and the transportation
revolution in the 19th century then
geography has work shifts and the disc
allergy it becomes a different kind of
issue oh but mens rea lynn nevertheless
remains a strategic space as a native
space or as integral function normally
in the colonial sense or malls himself
but also because of the British system
you were cool that Vicky spoke yesterday
about ricin an American who writes 1948
about possibility
turning the material into an object of
US policy after the Truman Doctrine why
he says is the the Mediterranean is
dubious unity however it does have a
system attached to it and you it refers
doesn't use that word but that's what it
needs and that is the British system the
previous system is now only a form
without content and has their resource
it's therefore we have resources we have
to fill the British system which is a
native system which is an imperial
system are any emphasizes eastern
Mediterranean but it actually involves
then sudden strong points gibraltar more
the Suez Canal Cyprus eastern
Mediterranean Sea uncivil Turkey and
Greece and so his kind of reinvented
regional policy is giving giving the
British system American Muscle succeed
in John Bull pure and simple so there is
in that sense of regional languages
fatigue naval our perspective easy to
scrape the surface of that idea you'll
find my hand you will find the late 19th
century or the 20th century reflection
on the importance of navies for food
purposes and covering great power and
the example of England which is what the
hand theorizes the most well
disseminated thinker of the late
nineteenth centuries is the American
Admiral Mahan are you theorized it's on
the basic from a historical history the
brilliant example being and our teachers
from that the notion that the United
States being an island as
imagine it but my England shall tell the
crib it into the equivalent of the
Mediterranean there's a lot of talk in
the legend early late nineteenth and
early twentieth century about the
Mediterranean as an example of a space
constitutive of great power in the naval
sense and that all great power
ultimately is about the English example
and the kid of them revises in saudi
arabia into the inverter side arm and
said them enable the aspect of the
Mediterranean is more or less constant
throughout there is always a way you can
think about the Mediterranean from an
alien standpoint and there is a
relatively autonomous US and British our
traditional thought about the
Mediterranean as needing space which has
its own lordship has it done God
depending on the technology in circle ah
as I said the north-south to new
perspective these are intersects with
that naval aspect but it isn't the
setting and so these you colonization
decolorization enters into the picture
and much of this conference and
preceding conference has been about how
does the phenomenon of colonialism and
the auxiliary decolonization intersect
with the problematic of the terrible
there's been nothing belongs to that
issue are here i'm reminded of Senator
John F Kennedy in in the 1950s are in a
notorious and unorthodox move rotation
by the ongoing struggle anterior says
it's
basically that the curveball and
decolonization of two discrete processes
they are not the same and the United
States it's incumbent upon the United
States at a world power that stands be
in the Mosul bad news to have a policy
and a standpoint on decolonization which
is independent of the standpoint that we
have the US has on a pimple since the
two processes are discreet and
autonomous are designed decolonization
should not be interpreted or decided
upon are on the premise that has
something to do intrinsic you the code
well this he was given a lot of flak by
the New York Times and others on
anything be four the initiative issue of
Algeria and the problems that that
speech or those arguments were was said
to have destructive effect that it was
said to have on the negotiations going
on between France and Algeria for
regarding anterior but also because
impossibility of gray with the orthodoxy
or terrible I have to say that that
Senator giant penny when he became
president kennedy discovered that this
was not so much as I admire that
standpoint and the car took express it
somebody is ie to become you know the
next president of the United States even
when 20 the same dissing itttt oh it's
nevertheless quite quite incorrect to
say that these two things are from the
imagine standpoint discrete processes
they are not discrete parentheses from
that standpoint tool ah but a very
simple reason that anything the United
States does at the 19
it is my way of geopolitics are acting
in the world is ultimately
overdetermined in the last incident and
the last instance arrived again and
again in any game are barred the third
war as the u.s. project so I would
insist are there there is no way
ultimately of reading anything outside
that framework in short it's monastery
everything that happened is a product
again but it is to say that there is no
way after with me that you can stand up
and defend to the teeth that these
things are independent of one another
nothing is independent if you want to
look at what the United States does
doesn't it in the world from the
ultimately determining decision on the
truth there is nothing outside to match
them which you can say the day with our
needs and we left but it is say that it
is over determinant cast across every
single aspect or what the United States
doesn't doesn't did arm and so from that
standpoint I think Jericho's really
wrong ah that's why I also think that
Iran is quite wrong ah our killer war is
not um he's not here but nevertheless it
should be here right yes the categories
not it's not a classroom or my patience
or in equal you know universalizing
modernization on one side fashion within
an equal universe arising organization
on the outside this is quite wrong it's
to reread or re-inject the 1970s all the
1940s and forget about or be the limit
of emergence of the term or which is an
American one rnin system it's an
American project is fine American terms
is a not even Churchill's terms slightly
beds but not right oh and there's only
not star
are the terms of the curveball where the
curve was constituted formulating
discursive afraid you need are our us
terms in no uncertain terms and one
happening might have to recognize that
historically the idea of clashing
modernization is historically fools it's
historically cause empirically wrong we
should not say that there isn't that
what my surgeon down the line once the
advance the game is opportunities right
well once we actually have a structure
or what we actually have a system but
that's different from the constitution
of the form and the constitution in the
form in this case is is is the natural
recognition it's a matter of diplomacy
and recognition and takeover of the
nodes of world war two form and I'm not
going to bore you with the actual
details of that but the Cold War to put
it in the city of this possible way is
the answer to the question in colloquial
terms these unique question in what
possible form is it possible is it is is
it is it doable to put the United States
into the world on a global scale
politically economically by the bubble
strategically in peacetime against every
single tradition from his etc in 1787 89
and make that composition are answerable
in nineteen forty-six forty-seven
forty-eight and the answer is a recast
version of the Hitler argument
World War two the framework and that's
then the longer the source of it after
that it's an honorable prison
proposition United States has to be
global the United States has to stop the
Russian the United States has to have
and do what it takes and then you have a
space of strategic reasoning which has
to do with giving extra my and
squabbling over what that means in
concrete terms and that's where the
Mediterranean and indices the
proceedings in the nineteen fifties it
becomes you know a face which is
multifaceted as a strategic investment
from that standpoint are that has
contingents specific issues arising out
of that framework but as long as our
said yesterday it is in fact concretely
to look at continued events of what
happens in the Mediterranean in the
fifties on them largely a u.s. project
largely a years from now I woke up in
this morning and I say that
my composure introduce our my knee is
that Miller who helped me out in the
early 80s when I was lost and not found
in Washington DC and trying to get to be
archives and figure out where I was
doing ah and he was the more
knowledgeable about archives and the ins
and outs of how to do things important
than anybody else i came across ah he's
now at Georgetown II want you to be at
the State Department handling the
correlation serious and struggling I
think with some success against spots a
tea party but that's not what I mean how
to get things publisher are insensitive
um he was especially at that time oh I
salsa 93 probably all honesty and he's
been especially violent as knowledgeable
people I think about him to be ever
since but he's expanded that and become
an expert of home but her Mediterranean
or the northern side of it please put it
that way from Spain to Greece and
ziegler assignment all stuff that is
written about Italy are he's written a
widely traded reason for all the United
States is making more decrease history
empower 1950s 1974 do yeah great you
think that's right it's fine well you
okay you see this goes back a long way
okay um yeah this is done a nice job of
first character of what this is for this
time you're going to respond to this and
I will invite about a moderate way but
this is all three took any but I think
he had a good point that somebody ought
to put it on the table and shut up about
it so I'm going to sort summarized by
own conclusions in the first 15 20 pages
of his paper something like this the
first question I asked was is the
Mediterranean to type of the entity that
could create a single policy and because
is what firms need apartment background
but I come down as a bro Navy did the US
have a Mediterranean strategy and my
answer to that is no but allowing for
that and auto in fact were in fact
giving it to precedence over theory can
we can start the set of books and I'm
all in one which to base some kind of
credible analysis US foreign policy and
Nicole fourth period in the
Mediterranean and I think the answer
there is probably so I what I'm going to
do very briefly as outlined some of
these books so I see and you see there
are some differences between myself and
my distinguished friend over here on
this matter and the first piece what's
is in fact modernization but i would
understand modernization as the desire
of the realization by a nice in the area
that they had a change or else and for
the Independent States view
mediterranean region spain portugal
italy latter late please this is a
process retrieve against the end of the
eighth
he carries on 19th century the search
for modernization as it means
maintaining independent status was
reflected with the idea of nationalism
for the colonial dependencies the 20th
century obviously the point at which
having or be in the process of exiting
from foreign domination the question of
modernization becomes an absolutely
critical one was how do we maintain
ourselves as and identity in the world
so I was situated halfway in the middle
homeless versus Egypt which impact had a
first run of modernization in the early
19th century but way of dating seventy
or eighty eighty four and then calm
itself once again reduced the colonial
status of the British Empire which
diving a very interesting case so what
we have there is a certain commonality
from the point of view of the
Mediterranean states in will be driven
effort to modernize this is about social
status it's about economic position
within society it's also about plural
security and broken comes into issue in
this context it seems to me there's a
logical link between the United States
mistakes in the Mediterranean and that
is that the United States ultimately and
actually from the beginning looks like
the best and possibly the unique
interlocutor to develop these kind of
strategies of modernization and I think
up it was very revealing yesterday's
he's professor
no I purposely asked him what appeared
to be assume the dumb question about two
or maybe dumb comment about American
officials of the kind of crisis like
this would they hope that you would in
fact respond in the way he did which was
to say that haven't sketched out for us
the reasons why a gypped is likely over
the next couple of decades to find
himself in a very close alliance with
the United States even denounced the
United States for 30 years of idiotic
policy or the policy was so idiotic wire
to be gypsum signing up for another run
so the very nature of the American
situation is that it really is
increasingly across the cold or the only
game in town the early period of the
Cold War I think you could argue that or
in fact to ideological systems in
conflict is a number speakers pointed
out the Soviet Union began to lose
traction pretty early on in this process
and fighting acuities certainly this
later Cold War the US has no real
strategic threat in
feels having said that let me turn to be
young to the other side of this game
villains do you want anything
modernization as I understand it is also
very appealing to America policymakers
because it fits in very well with
certain ideological predispositions
central ones are in fact in the code of
American exceptionalism old the United
States is the society model society for
human development which is which is
visible has a really honest the
foundation of the American Republic what
changes I think across two centuries is
the way in which this role as carry out
that is say in the 19th century the
American power is relatively restricted
Americans tend to do their missionary
work largely through non-governmental
agencies particularly American
missionaries but also Americans involved
and create accomplished richard
etheridge in the 20th century of course
the United States government has emerged
as the main spirit area both of the
American group of their national
organization and twittering stand also
as a little spear carrier for occasional
the station so there is a fundamental
power equation that's different here
okay so let's just pass on to some of
the policy for hidden Mediterranean and
the Cold War period the first one
obviously is anti-communism my colleague
porterdale but let me stress sort of
trends argument on its head and suggest
you that the basic struggle is not in
fact between the United States and
sodium per se but and beautiful
Washington is between the United States
and national communist parties because
the fundamental distinction what the
Washington perceives throughout this
period is that he come to this party of
Italy or Portugal or wherever is going
to take power and then make this portion
of Mediterranean part of the Soviet
sphere of it will its source first
international practice partners subject
the Soviet Union I'm you see this a lot
in the terminology that's used 14 n
dimensional conscious parties is ensure
the doctor they're dangerous armed
minorities any more broad sense there
seems cat's-paws and so did you but the
idea in Mediterranean basically on the
nation by nation basis is to counteract
parties I people go further if you take
away any eisenhower dr of 1957 the
gyroid regard is kind of a poor man's
from the doctrine I Eisenhower
effectively takes me in theology of all
time obviously actual parties to an
extreme he's even a post in the areas
where they pretty clearly don't exist
and a lot of the American policy in the
Middle East is the search for dangers
communist parties which in fact of what
we've been suppressed by modernizing but
authorities regime to the area again
against an intention to yesterday if you
see it particularly Magic Maker media
when the Iraq situation goes down at
casino sudden as you know Iraqi dictator
suddenly as soon as the perfect catspaw
from the intraday economist with Soviet
Union supported so it certainly
anti-communism since he kind of a foot
for understanding the urban policy a
second point I'd like to talk about and
probably divided into areas is near
allergy one of the questions that was
asked yesterday repeatedly is a question
of American attitudes toward
decolonization has been brought up again
today we I think it turns a great
American foreign policy it really is the
importance of ideologies in this
particular area and I point to a book
which I nearly love infrequently used to
my students over georgetown by michael
hunter called etiology american foreign
policy the amazing thing about this book
which is written during here is actually
has nothing to really allergy it's a
better title would have been callin
pathologies of American foreign policy
practice in which time does a wonderful
job of showing exactly the areas in
which American foreign policy has really
deviated from its ideological next what
he does not do which is which I kind of
spell because of the body who worked at
the Dundee and that has been done
subsequently of course we are in the age
of the Tea Party is talking about before
founding fathers view of foreign policy
and here you see beginning of April
center and the establishment of ideas
about the US rule is a model and also
the us-run was an
leader of other societies and water
stored the pursuit of happiness to drop
their representative government the
Pacific happiness and always a better I
think guide to understanding American
foreign policy of ideologies probably
Benedict Anderson samajik abilities and
it has by the way an interesting spin
off highly recommend thinking about
organizing James Facebook about the
western Mediterranean chaotic century
which does a wonderful job in a ready to
be ology with practice it also deals the
greatest era positions of decolonization
one of the things that strikes me is
that the United States funds its origins
is to the national state and they
extremely important of a bit of
sovereignty and that's led us to draw a
set of conclusions about international
affairs which are extremely important
one is that the United States in terms
of its entering into the international
system its management in its
relationships and making Thank You
felicity has had a tendency basically to
accept system as it exists that is to
say when the United States that's going
in the 1920s century it was basically
accepted the notion that out there would
be a whole set up for potentially
hostile European empires at the same
time learn policymakers when we
consistently have
based national States and as the
colonization process it emerges actually
let's go back to step in the 19th
century has the process the creation of
independent particularly relating
germany loses l forward Americans
American policymakers and I've argued
most Americans very comfortable with
this kind of development similarly on
the area of decolonization seems to me
the United States was reasonably
comfortable with colonization as long as
it could not imply the rival and power
of the National Happiness party at which
point all bets are off see this process
is Andrew suggested working its way out
20th century I'd also suggest another
disappointing areas in which the United
States own at least temporarily
temperature somebody else's were
knowledgeable about individual countries
and I and that is the United States has
never been seen as necessarily opposed
to the processes of decolonization
within this structural framework so it's
a way in which American comfort comfort
level with the colonization fit in when
the sort of desires of various folks
Colin Farrell so relative the
ideological and also practical comfort
zone ization which in turn reinforces I
think the natural attraction between us
policymakers in US policy individual
states of the region is converging need
to go on and suggest something else this
is an issue that's come up again and
again and probably will come up again in
the enemies of the issue of
democratization in an earlier version of
myself I used to infer the DISA
stabilization politics and what I'm
talking about yesterday a power that is
essentially oriented towards status
protocol things can see values in the
process of democratization but their
limits the American commitment at least
impact as opposed to the rhetoric in
other words the United States its public
statements where that where there's
always the Norse concept party people
enjoying the same freedom to Americans
do how is it practical matter American
policymakers regarding the process of
democratization I think you're seen it
right now lead as something that arises
you need internal structures in the
society and therefore is not something
that the United States is going to go
out of us tickets and a downtown in fact
i'm a very believer in the humphrey
bogart theory foreign policy and some of
you may remember at the certain point in
this idealistic you won't pass a blog
that quote our turns to be the leader of
the european resistance all dressed
appoint inferences you're alive stick my
neck out for nobody this is I think a
classic definition of real practice in
terms of democratization its value is in
the tool of stabilization so you put
your unit channel practice has been the
United States gets on rather well with
its fellow democracies back
kind of serious major Colvin's now
implicit in this also looking at these
sort of in front of the label as opposed
to the caveats later with on the back
when the u.s. democratization level is
in fact enormous gap between American
rhetoric and American practice and again
you can see this very lucky enough in
events that are going on in Egypt right
now I just like to throw this out for
consideration exactly what could the
united states have done to forward the
Democratic aspirations Egyptian people
in the last couple weeks would be to go
for him into going down the road in
terms of doing this and my suggestion
that since forces obviously not on the
table and I would recommend your very
difficult to get a corporal starts their
citizens together to support the idea
but any military dimension of things
went wrong engine then you have to use
the traditional to its diplomacy and
that really constricts durability
guiding ever in this process or
democratization process secondly I'd
like to just point out that there are
cases in which the United States has
felt so forced to democratize other
societies and risking world war two
example comes to mind to Germany Japan
and Friends the Italians and the
American process there has been rather
interesting first of all it is always
been perceived as a short term process
get in and get out I don't think anybody
thought they'd get in and get out as
fast as George Bush did but and horse
stable under as a result but essentially
American planning has been based around
the observation that what you want to do
in cases of really Maryland opponents
societies in which it seemed to
policymakers that the dangers of a
wreath of a recidivism of the same kind
of practice work strength and strong
German whatever you want to call it
activities in the Indian station you
said in military force you occupied the
country and then we begin the process of
democratization of establishing trade or
free enterprise and muscle totally
motivated critics and packages are Lions
competed in my country this implies
appropriate role in the longer you stay
the more difficult it becomes in fact to
projector long-term influencing society
in order you become the object of public
discontent so it's not me alone
Elizabeth somebody quite much more
sophisticated in any case I would also
point out in terms of the way in which
Americans carrying an alphas policy it
goes right back in be illogical and
members of the country that American
occupation policy played clearly based
on the ordinance of 1787 that
established the way in which the
so-called Northwest Territories were
created and that this template is
extremely important because the Jews and
every subsequent exchanging American
state and therefore the military
officials will be familiar with it and
in fact apply the label 98 in philippine
islands and find of every well where
else is there this is a wonderful
example of how we are in fact way when
we turn this subject they came up
yesterday which I was totally unprepared
for which strikes me also mention
there's a lot of talk in this group and
I think why's it so about the
relationship between America and the
british empire in the mediterranean and
with certain reservations i'd like to
endorse that notion and we were in fact
a successor state didn't breach in
eastern Mediterranean but let me also
point out a couple of things that they
have over here what I think the most
fundamental when it was that we did not
expect any engines the Mediterranean 30w
to do not really expect place the breach
in eastern Mediterranean in fact gotas
your inner partnership sharing we want
to be principle of constructs American
wartime policy the second fact is that
at least until November 1943 the Brits
were calling a shot of the two in terms
of overall allies strategy in the West
it's quite evident that when the
Roosevelt me for children between june
and 42 and began of 40 30 at casablanca
at every opportunity we reach imposed by
the Americans their strategic region EG
what up going from south to north and
reinforcing the base of operation troll
meditate november of 43 and it sort of
blinding moment the United States lips
the lips game on the threats against
early dictate the strategy by which we
were one of the Second World War this is
there were a couple of actual physical
factors the most important is the size
of American contribution more effort
or production but also in terms of
empower at this point British part
secondary us to us is the primary us a
moment of war materials second way is
that no one well certainly people in the
American administration very aware of
breach economic weakness and in some
cases want you to exploit this breakup
DJ the Imperial trade preferences nobody
appears you're really contemplated or
understood a degree to which brittany is
going down the tubes economically nor
did the British and as a result is
somebody pointed out yesterday we get
these from moments in which British
appear in the offering and their policy
approach and run into less to American
opposition in many cases and more to the
realities of climate so there is a
transferable power but it is not
necessarily an American desire so much
to replace the breach as a kind of
informal step-by-step replacements kind
of state of power that's no longer able
to carry its own right in the
Mediterranean and there's a great deal
of ambivalence on replacing the finishes
to go to power particularly authorities
so in any case my conclusion is that
would sort of a fifth results into this
and understand and we're trying to
extract an idea however in policy is
carried out only
mediterranean i think that probably
historians understood the best creation
evilest by the native Chris twiddle that
basic theory strategy is in fact to
accept the way in which Mediterranean is
bigger that is to say with its strong
error based component along the southern
maryland and Middle East with a unique
set of problems involving so called
urban tier with a European Mediterranean
angle to and sort of begin by looking at
these kind of sub divisional areas in
which American policy operating on a
comparative basis now when I use the
term imperative I'm not talking about
trying theater one-size-fits-all in
relationship for rather see what the
United States did in relation to say
expanding Italy Portugal Greece and also
see where the differences lie because i
think it as much as anything the
differences are is telling us prepare
our else that way then if you operate on
this subculture no context put the
European experience on a submarine
context into just position with the
Middle Eastern policy and also I'd say a
separate North Africa policy it need to
be able to arrive at a much more
coherent understanding of exactly 20
years that the Americans were doing
during this 40-year period I do believe
the difference is ours importance of
similarity so my Mediterranean history
might be described as yes button and I
think I'll stop right there thank you
I think of the questions we can come
back to your concrete artemis by degrees
or if I'm learning empirical apparently
display my new client says my my dream
is listed here as a commentator but is
not a commentator these kids bring his
interception table arm arm as an
attendee area or reserve as a as an
addition or as a paper in his own right
on the Browse is doing a personal
appearance with here at Columbia having
earned his doctorate at the y on
tropical phalanges the institute or
solid didn't studies is that arise from
translation and he's the author of a
monograph on a las cabezas I guess in
the market is around is tourism is
definitely Hebrews hot muggy to tonight
did he write up on market to listen what
about what is our medicines or we can do
this and what is not in America yeah
preparing the 1940s yeah right here sort
of contested actually yeah oh he's also
an editor of the army literary star this
video's political and he will talk
mainly about you Iberian Peninsula yes
try to bring in the West Indies or any
authority to
so the westin it surrounded the West
meets our onion basically source
portable and from the spin foods can be
consider as the rear bar of the organism
saranya within the worse than security
and intense system such as the starting
point that should be like know the
position of these two regimes at the end
of the second level basically the third
part of the to receive with the trend
may basin and then the origins of Borg
regimes for especially their attitudes
during the Second World War when
Portugal due to this traditional link
with religion remain Muslim community
and when practiced paint tried to enter
into the nasty new order into the
turning point of the world until late
nineteen forty seriously and if your
answers because hillary wants you to
create to pay the price first after the
end of the second world war together
with the members where the spanish civil
war is to them a very powerful memories
and members of the foods cooked a severe
one at that time the europe and in a
perfect political document pragmatism
that there was soon applied to all the
papers in unacceptable in the case of
the relationship with with the Franco
regime projects also swore to garland
promise came whirling by n3t called
available that was signing 9200 moon in
938 so during the resolution of cargo
regime of course road atlas bridge to
concept of the other Western Western
countries through the Portuguese
diplomacy as a result of this two
different situation portugal was more or
more or less insulator the nous devons
net force since nineteen forty four when
they are not with us to establish a navy
base in rogers in the forest iceman in
1944 that Billy bass was was very
important because it allows when so
crucial routes versus the Atlantic and
so it was the masses for example were
trying to convince her for the
Portuguese and Spanish to study so many
days or in the canary island or Indians
for assume that exactly they're coming
from coming from the other side and and
the same direction books when we came
member of not all 49 and benefit from
the Marshall Plan and entering to the
organization for European and you can
Economic Cooperation and the results i
have be like 0 to 80 into the tent
assistance with the US 19 it was only
splitted and mostly by your own
decisions of the first letters from the
first attempt over Europe any poisonous
for example we had Congress and but it
was maybe because house i was still
attending other time the european
doctoring super important still data a
very powerful porn an environment is
document which should be interesting to
see how does it fit in there into the
ministry and studied in North and South
procedure African like the perfect
economic and
southern Europe on the first season of
practice been promised state was was
condemning me to not post them and yet
the aliasing said negotiations with
Republican which was in exile in Mexico
and but at the same time they're
establishing the negotiations as well
with the monarchists there were maybe
basting in portable and trying also to
me to go back to me to Spain that was
one of the many products of their
position of the regime because it wasn't
you advice in / events and this one
syllable so again the mark is the one
side next time and also we got the
comments funny that in ninety 44 that
the Communist Party was mainly based on
Moscow in Mexico's well and
embarrassment in southern France and
taking other particles with
bargain-priced roots in the manual it
took them and try to explain to the
consequence Tyson at work Bucky's and
early years that that's very nice foot
forward burn but alas still need of the
take these so again they never kind of
wig we shud some the routine that much
but I still was a communist party on it
and as he was the bridge Civil War at
the same time an opposition of the
regime was solid ice at the same sender
the prologue created any acidity and in
the ratings love
was one of the main concerns of the the
bridge is the present and under in the
US spain of course wasn't allowed to
join the United Nations and the United
Nations from them officially there was
in my position and we recommend to to
recall all the ambassadors from the
country which in fact they they did
apart from Switzerland and Argentina
make me your device w another Mary
Argentina was a relationship or lower
gina at that moment with her own and
they even studies and women prefer only
for you and then afterwards spain was
also the spirit of a master plan and
from from nature so from the American
perspective the decision of studying the
negotiations whoo-hoo linked to the to
the women of 53 really fits perfectly
with logical I us understanding of the
situation because on the one hand those
of the Rising companies parties
involving Syrian friends especially
regarding the elections of Fourier the
poo in chiapas oaxaca the waste of this
ability of the very insular and that all
surprised that the Americans were not
willing to pay as he was no clear
Democratic insanity and so when the
container doctrine was was announced and
with the start of the Korean War so in
the soon depends upon the magnitude 60
or spanning the system of military bases
worldwide with flexible work
arrangements and that basically the
Mediterranean was to incorporate reasons
to into nature but also to reinforce the
system facilities in Morocco in Portugal
and Nancy Communists came what were
those facilities important they will
provide a great of death of the
difference of the region in case of an
attack coming from the Soviet Union
because the pioneers were conceived like
the natural barrier like the first lap
solution in case of study attack and
also because the spectrum 57 Tortorella
in sunny Spain were out of the range of
the missiles from the Soviet Union and
Doug had to face the b-47 of your bumper
and for the massive response that it was
flying in case of a spin attack so for
example in Portugal which of our service
natural strategy of providing regular
basis that that sounds too to the better
in surveys in southern Portugal which
was one of the most important basis in
sunny southern Europe on the other hand
it was not only military from stands
were also like in certain political
circles in the US the conservative
Catholic if it was mostly certain were
created at the time of the Civil War
started to say learn the Boise to wear
the proper spelling were most alien like
civil union and the words are always the
studies decisions who tend to the policy
sort of thing and the sooner the wall
street journal will say regarding the
Nemesis it will stay the US will finish
with this stupid idea that nest eastern
only be associated with conscious
ability deeply so so in a way apart from
the from their own
from the owners facilities a scalar
dispensable procedure was a victim of
the investment policy during the Civil
War period was again getting as a result
and after several negotiations in
especially with properly under 1751 the
woman's so-called awareness oh man it
was signing in 53 and down into the
military mucho the fashion and economic
aid and cinda williams and they profit
from the word executive agreements the
one on sweetie she was acting like this
there was he wasn't nearly as Senator
approval that could be put in verse from
the agreement and ass are solely those
obtained three-year basis was in
civilian mcguigan and a marinade base in
importer and other facilities including
myself monitoring brothers in the
heisman but also bring in spring and
puts who go into the system applied
already directed in Soudha because for
so very place on moda as well most
immediate and bringing Spain also
possibility to the Protectorate Morocco
which it's still Spanish another time of
other sign of effectiveness and western
genre so but this situation will change
in frequency
repentance to the persons that were in
terms of negotiations for example in my
retainer is the special memory of videos
in plastic on lincoln MKT who was the
American ambassador in Madrid in search
optimization but before I mean
ambassador enrichment also during the
great Civil War II was at that time
enactment and George Strait for example
was the marshall college student
portugal and then various reasons with
ergonomic part of this conservative i
think we may be kind of question
ourselves over if there was any kind of
special it's a random vision for
clearing the negotiations with that
specific can you type of conference so
that sadly the sink just one single
policy learn English different single
position sensor even different
formulations and leave it so a person
that you open your paper about power
ports and was your movements of two to
three to the survival of authority and
mr. ography is almost anonymous over
that he knows we sent the resume was
really clearly related bye bye TC p and
indesign supervenience one with the
Vatican one over with that with the US
and that worked sense all other
political support based on Marianne has
a common ideology and making also
without any kind of liberation
there's no loss or pre messenger or even
an attention to look back and you don't
swallow the regime to enter into the
West under that system offer was from
the battle with executive women but in
any case that is this turns into a
stable friendship between chosen paper
shipment and us to the very end of the
regime what one of the things that
symbolize this importance for demise is
that the front for sample them never one
never went abroad apart from invited to
be filled bordighera performance in
mussolini and what one time we went to
this mutual to meet salsa and i'm on the
contrary the opposite side was against
Salazar coming to Madrid your one was to
create a very generous is more well no
because it was the topic of one of the
novel so no recent novel price what was
your son for peace international ability
and and the other one was true what were
three American president dr. was the
only head of state specific evidence in
front was eisenhower in 59 mix when in
70 and for insolence o'clock so from
that article that the situation will
change along along the 57 60s and
concerning the Portuguese case for
example it was very table to colonial
wars Colonials want to start in Angola
69 Indian 63 Muslim between 64 and
course on an arms embargo from the
so it was maybe because they were
compromised with the pronunciation and
at the same time the agreement of that
without military base in innovation via
source were spotted in 62 so they may be
a center so the Portuguese that were
really angry about this constant verbal
then I do anyone every race and but the
Americans were allowed to use it and you
can use it in this in a stable 76 ena so
but depending on the window solace and
one day we will say that it's no more
time to use season text and on the
contrary when the protector a horrible
being the gang around during the
pendency 56 parents turn them into the
family / games into the pending
decolonization because of episode 0
alpha that they try to put your sides of
triangle of the immunization so so we
can see again that have a core issues
such as the polarization were used to
try to fulfill a traditional national
interest as it was to try to understand
performances at the same time with an
accessibility of the Maghreb region the
Spanish language when either of the army
for very important things in a sense for
the yourself there wasn't really like
very powerful things but this unit is
important because neighbors are
skeptical
even send delegations of the party suit
to study the system of the single
birthday explain and so little and that
those kind of relationships and so again
we can see the world like different
strategies to to approach this kind of
me on national news stainless junction
named and we can include on outputs of
Portugal and Spain through the picture
so I get as a Hispanic places were
getting more important because of this
over Portuguese and we can see live in
every radio net negotiations in 63 in 17
states apart Spanish semesters further
looking and if a new foreign policy and
imposing conditions holla mohalla to do
and to American negotiators as well as
the relationship with your rest of the
listing you were getting more intense
and they even apply for enter into a
year of an Iranian 62 to summarize for
modernization full economic development
also that the u.s. us a sign in 50
people were very important all they
receive around fifty percent of 137 the
most unkind but anyway it allows to to
prevent collapse and the public rooms to
line were really important also
in terms of how the positive impact
moving the whole economy Brazil's
economy and also because been linked
with with his military and economic
areas over some technical and irrigation
and provenance what all the students to
go to come to the u.s. to tell me like
new management program system not only
recognize will also in sociology from
somebody's is at that time when a young
scientist to be mean oppositely into the
size facility and come back to suspended
from the research analysis race into
into the new sensation in the sixties
and so we more or less Vegas what
policies are very we can see it very
symbolizing in popular culture for
example we brought you probably all know
Auggie's welcomes emotion in that
direction in Google that cutter in
reflects very much like the aim of the
population really like the improving
nails and also given that also one of
the most popular inside I cannot resist
to decide one of the most popular salsa
at that time things perfectly done to
Coco battery and the phone from the US
and Franco who consider himself as a
military team is doing
the Civil War after Gabriel subjectively
starts about himself the first person
who really defeat the Soviet Union in
battlefield now have the fitness or not
necessarily but just me and in the
Spanish Civil War so we got these
military genius as changing the council
of ministers on TLC's finest minister so
how has a situation i say excited he
will work available this is anything we
can go out that this is how to see once
reducing which is the credible world the
federal war on the US let's beg them to
live lead us to invade us and then to
rid us of that and so rather remain
silent let's say I just in one problem
what it takes to me please will be very
much notice that a perception and
behavior also the same network topology
and last but but at least this
contradictions on they don't have to say
is inside of the cover was already want
and this wasn't a communist country on
Earth so but American barbaracle not be
based on promoting democracy because he
was not a good combo for the regime so
they kind of focus more or less than the
understand from the American lifestyle
living but that very when in democracy
came that the image of the United States
what were a link to promote a noticeable
to sustain in a papacy so the roots of
the of the anti-americanism
indispensable to put so is made
nominated in the beginning in widening
widening in the Catholic purpose the
woods are contaminated in pain comes
from from from the Hopi and the best
example is that to be used illustrator
that have been taking place in the hole
during passing period in Spain haven't
even against the Turk the Baskervilles
woman or in general stars were into
knowledge here 86 when there was a
referendum about joining the nature and
women were remaining with the services
and and the other one was in 2003
against the information in thank you
okay that's a conversation I'm own
position for the third punic so I came
here to use talking first about the
midst of and down and I like to raise a
question for some more about
general so I was wondering if you could
tell us something so you start out by
saying Americans that is not
modernization is striking that historian
would be selling I reduced it using the
term that emerges in the nineteen
fifties for some set of processes or
some set of them or institution
Confederate that exists much earlier so
one only wonder if you could tell us
about something about the actual terms
that will net or the thing that you
think those bacteria years let's say
when the profession we do when
intellectual the journals are being
created that should discuss